good morning
and again I welcome you to the Mount
Olivet Cathedral Church here in Memphis
Tennessee
let us begin with a word of Prayer
Lord we are grateful and thankful
for your many blessings
we ask now that you would be with us
be with this family
give Grace and strength for them
be with
attorney cromp and his team as they
labor for justice
be with the city
as we deal with
all of the news and
deal with all that we have to deal with
in days to come
God we ask your blessings as we share
today
we pray in Jesus name
amen
it is my delight to bring on again today
attorney Crump who is America's uh black
uh attorney general a fighter for
justice a fighter for peace
and we ask him to come at this time
give him a hand as he comes
[Applause]
thank you
thank you so much Pastor Thomas again
for allowing us to be in your Cathedral
uh
I'm Attorney Ben crumpin along with
attorney Tony rominucci attorney
Ernestine Doris and attorney Van Turner
who is also the president of the
Memphis chapter of the NAACP
we are proud to represent the family of
Tyree Nichols also present with us of
course is uh Bishop Williamson who has
been a steady uh Faith leader for us in
this ordeal as well as Kareem Ali who is
uh a Memphis native who
is uh my investigator but also is a
person in the community who even before
the video came out the community
activists were saying that something
isn't right about this so I want to
thank all those Community activists and
all those Community people who stood up
for justice even before we showed up
even before the camera showed up I think
they deserve a big round of applause
[Applause]
and we have the SCLC president here as
well
uh
and obviously we have the people most
affected
by this tragedy who are showing such
Grace
on the
these tragic circumstances
that is the stepfather
of Tyree Nichols Mr Rodney Wells and the
mother of Tyree Nichols Miss rovon Wells
can never applaud you enough for your
grace and dignity throughout this so
what are we here for today
at this hour we're here to give a
reaction
to the charges that were announced by
district attorney Moore Roy yesterday
and to
give remarks and anticipation
of
the last documentation
of Tyree Nichols alive on this Earth
and so we began
with our reactions to the charges
and
we applaud
the district attorney
for bringing charges against the five
officers
for
second-degree murder aggravated assault
aggravated kidnapping uh official
misconduct
and official oppression
very important charges
against these five offices
as Pastor Thomas refers sometimes I am
referred to as black America's Attorney
General
and
we stand on the principle of equal
justice
so let me be exceedingly clear on this
point
when we look at
how these five black officers
who were caught on camera committing a
crime
and when we look at how fast
the police chief and the police
department
terminated them
and we look at how swiftly
the district attorney bought charges
against them in less than 20 days
Mama then we want to Proclaim that this
is the blueprint going forward
for any time any officers whether they
be black or white
will be held accountable no longer can
you tell us we got to wait six months to
a year even though we got a video with
evidence of the excessive force in the
crime no more can you tell us that
anymore because with these five black
officers
you all move this swiftly
and
as the chief said it was important for
the community
that they took Swift action
and that Justice moved swiftly
against these five officers who happen
to be African-American well
when it's white officers we think it's
also important to the community that
there is Swift action
and that we move swiftly to Justice
I mean comes let's be honest let's think
about it this is not the first time that
we saw police officers
committing crime and engaging and
excessive brutal force against black
people in America who are earned all
but yet we have never
seen Swift Justice like this think about
laquan McDonald in Chicago Illinois
attorney where was that over a year
14 months even though they had that
video on day one
think about the video of Eric Garner in
Staten Island New York how long it took
uh Kareem on that one think about all
these cases out in Sterling silky in
Baton Rouge Louisiana on video
think about Pamela Turner Houston Texas
killed on video it took a year for them
to bring charges in her case even though
they had the video day one
think about Ronald green
in Louisiana
I mean have that video for day one took
over a year to bring charges against
them I mean
so many man my God
think about 14 year old Tamir rice
on video
and
why Justice didn't move swiftly for any
of these
black people when they were killed by
white police officers so we have to make
the point exceedingly clear we now have
the blueprint America
and we won't accept less going forward
in the future we won't have black
officers treated differently than white
officers we want Equal justice under the
law Tyree deserved it Tamir race deserve
it we're on a green disparagement after
Sterling deserve it Eric Garner deserve
it Pamela attorney deserve it all our
children Byron Williams deserve it
I mean he was killed for riding the
bicycle while black in Las Vegas on
video
and yet the investigation is still going
on over a year
and so we have a precedent
that have been set here in Memphis and
we
intend to hold this blueprint
for All America from this day forward
now also
and you're going to hear from her
man what what Grace and dignity
for rhogon
tyree's mother
she said
previously that
she feels God
used her son as an assignment
and Bishop Williamson
even though it's very very painful and
God knows this
is tragic but she believes God used
her son as an assignment amen
and her and Mr well said this assignment
is for reform
reform that we can try to prevent some
of these hashtags
of black and brown people being unjustly
killed by police
that we can create a Tyree law
that's right here in Tennessee
that will be very
very well
emphasized in
police officers president Turner
to have a duty to intervene when they
see crimes being committed even if those
crimes are being committed by their
fellow officers that's it that will be
the appropriate Legacy that we give
Tyree Nicholson if we really think we
want Justice For Justice it's not just
Justice for one family it's justice for
all of us that's what rovonne is praying
for she wants reform
we want this duty to intervene to become
Tyrese law just like they have carry on
Horn's law in the state of New York and
for those of you who don't know that
sister as me an attorney Mac Arrow more
taught this morning
Carrie Ann horn was a black
police officer
she witnessed one of her fellow officers
brutalizing a black Citizen
and she to intervene and stop to me got
assaulted herself when she tried to stop
him but because she intervened
she was retaliated against
and she was terminated and had to fight
almost a decade-long barrel
to get Justice because they had no duty
to intervene for police officers before
her courageous Act and the issue is
we have to make it official we have to
make it documented we got to put it on
the books we have to have notice that
police officers you have a duty to
intervene when you see a crime being
committed
you expect the people
to say something
well I want y'all show us how to do it
you all go first when you see a crime
being committed and then people in our
community will feel a lot more
uh safe when they go intervene and say
we saw a crime when you want us to tell
what we saw well you tell what you saw
too amen
amen and so this is what Miss Rowe Vine
and Rodney and
Jamal and Kiwana and Michael his
siblings that's what they want they want
reform with these charges now before I
bring attorney Tony romanucci up to give
some remarks before we bring the family
we want to underscore just two more
points
number one
the fact
that
this unit
had engaged in this type of brutality
before
this unit had engaged in excessive use
of force against black citizens before
and attorney Roman Nucci and I plan to
make sure that is
pointed out in the civil case
on behalf of Tyree Nichols because
as
citizens have reached out to us and the
family
about this happened to them there's a
brother
who said
four or five days before this happened
to Tyree
that same scorpion unit
confronted him
while he was in his car going to get
pizza and he said that they used all
kind of profanity against them they uh
threw them on the ground talking about
where the drugs and where the weapons
and he was like Tyree and put a gun to
his head
and
this brother
after he survived this ordeal
he said he called to the police
department twice
to Internal Affairs twice
and they never responded to him
if they would have responded to him
we might not be here today that's right
that's right and so that's why we plan
on making sure any citizen in Memphis
who had to face the brutality of this
scorpion organized crime unit I guess as
their distinguished we'll come forward
we had a older gentleman right uh Mr
Reed
50 cents you're going to say he was
confronted
by this unit and he was brutalized and
he had pictures of his injuries
and so
it was for Sybil
it was for silver that something tragic
like this was going to happen when you
have police officers giving
as attorney ramanucci and uh our legal
team discussed not just immunity
but impunity to on the
constitutional rights
of people
who look a certain
color who lived in a certain community
and so we believe that this was a
pattern in practice
and Terry is dead because that pattern
in practice went unchecked by the people
who were supposed to check that and I I
think we are so thankful to Chief Davis
now her her leadership through this
ordeal should be applauded as an example
for other police Chiefs
in leadership
but we agree with her when she says
policy means nothing if you have a
culture
if that culture is rotten
you can make all the policy in the world
because the culture does not respect
policy
we have to make sure that the coaching
not only respects the policy but the
culture respects the community
and that is what we have to do
if we're going to give Tyree Nichols the
proper Legacy
and then finally
we think about
as Miss robine said
they came to our house
and they told her
she couldn't go to the hospital
and it wasn't until 4am in the morning
that the doctor called her
they told her that her son had been
pepper sprayed and tased and that he was
nearby
never told them
where they were at
and so we believe that we cannot allow
anybody to ever cover crimes against our
loved ones in our community it happens
far too much in America
and we have to have this conversation
over and over and over again
until it stops
we have to talk about this
institutionalized police culture that's
it that the
has this unwritten law that you can
engage in excessive use of force
against black and brown people
we have to have this conversation
because this institutionalized police
culture that
suggests you can do this to people in
certain communities who look a certain
way
cannot be tolerated
it doesn't matter if the officer is a
black officer a Hispanic officer or a
white officer it is the culture that
allows them to think they can do this to
Tyree that they can do this to Keenan
Anderson in Los Angeles California
that they can do it to Byron Williams in
Las Vegas
I mean to come and attack a black man
just for riding on a bicycle it is the
culture
and we have
to call out this culture every time we
get a chance we're going to call it out
call out the culture
we have to call out the
and that has to be the conversation or
those hashtags will continue to piled up
quicker than we can keep up
and the only way this is just the first
steps to getting Justice for Tyree
Nichols the only way we get for justice
for Tyree Nichols is it's the
institutionalized police culture that is
on trial today
and the only way we get Justice for
Tyree Nichols is if we call out this
institutionalized police culture so we
can get full Justice for Tyree Nichols
Justice for Tyree Nichols Justice for
Tyree Hills Justice
gestures for timing him justice
justice brutalities
[Music]
thank you all
now you're going to hear from a great
lawyer who fights for civil rights all
across America who I'm so proud to fight
wealth yet again on the front line
my brother attorney Tony Roman nuccio
will greet you and then we will continue
on with the press conference
thank you again ladies and gentlemen I
do have a few points to cover with you
today we were just here before you a few
days ago
but we have to lead from the top because
I really do want to talk to you a little
bit about these criminal charges the
gravity of the criminal charges and what
it means not only to these officers but
to this city-state and our country
remember this supposedly emanated from a
traffic stop which turned deadly and we
talked about what we saw in the video
when we were here before you Monday that
these were some of them were unmarked
squad cars these were not all officers
in uniform only partially of them were
you can call this the Scorpion unit if
that's what you want to call it but what
these really are because I do happen to
have subject matter expertise on this on
these cases
these are suppression units these are
saturation units and what they really
turn out to be are oppression units
and what they do is they wind up
oppressing the people that we care about
the most
our children
our young Sons and Daughters who are
black and brown because they are the
most vulnerable
make no mistake Tyree Nichols at all
times was an innocent victim on that
night he did nothing wrong he was caught
up in a sting this scorpion unit was
designed to saturate under the guise of
crime fighting and what it wound up
doing instead was creating a continual
pattern and practice of bad behavior
as Ben told you there are others who are
out there who have had similar
experiences and I will dare say
that when we get all the records that we
need that we will see a significant
Delta a disparity
between the use of force of the Scorpion
unit and that of the regular Memphis
Police Department and statistically on
average across the country and that is
because these saturation units are given
whispered
impunity Ben said it not immunity but
whispered impunity in order to carry out
their design
they can't collect guns they can't find
stolen cars unless they unwittingly trap
innocent people in this web
therefore
we are asking
Chief Davis
to disband this scorpion unit effective
immediately
[Applause]
the intent of the Scorpion unit has now
been corrupted it cannot be brought back
to center with any sense of morality and
dignity and most importantly trust in
this community how will the community
ever ever trust a scorpion unit
and that's what we are asking for
the intent was good
the end result was a failure and we must
recognize that and do something about it
and I call on all
Chiefs in this country to review their
saturation units to review their special
Squad units and disband them because
they can easily become corrupted when
they are told they are whispered in
their ear act with impunity
now
one of the charges is kidnapping
we're going to talk about the second
degree murder
but think about the weight of a
kidnapping charge being brought against
officers who are wearing a badge a
shield
carrying weapons on their duty belt
acting under the color of law
when has that happened in this country
and part of the definition of kidnapping
in the Tennessee statute
is that it's something that I'm going to
give another analogy to
when you think of 9 11 what's the word
that comes to mind terrorism
when you think of other heinous acts
that have happened in churches across
this country any Act of terrorism
what is that instill in you that ladies
and gentlemen is the definition that we
are dealing with here on this kidnapping
charge it is Terrorism it was designed
to terrorize the victim
this young man
by definition of the law in this state
was terrorized
not by one not by two but by five
officers who we now know that the
charges brought actually state that they
acted in concert with each other they
acted together as that pack of wolves
to inflict harm
terrorism
oppression of Liberty
oppression of constitutional rights
which led to murder
I just talked about all the charges in
nearly one sentence that is how this
case is going to be defined
this was an intentional act once those
officers were there they knew their
actions were going to cause death
and indeed it did sadly it did
we will take questions at the end of
this
but I do want to pick up on one thing
that Ben has said
and if I may add
this is the spokesperson for civil
rights in this country
we want to know
where are the unions
where does the Fraternal Order of Police
stand on this we have not heard from you
we want to hear from you
we want to hear you say
that what happened to Tyree what
happened to this family should never
ever happen again that you condemn the
brutality the savaging the terrorism the
heinousness
the vulgarity
of these actions
and we should all stand for that you
don't have to be a police Union we all
have to just have a soul and a heart
thank you amen
[Applause]
thank you so much attorney Rama Nucci
um
you know
one of the things that must be stated
about the kidnapping charge
Sarah when you all see this video
you're going to see
Tyrese
Nichols is
calling out for his mom
he calls out three times for his mother
his last words on this Earth
is Mom
mom
I mean he's screaming for her and when
you think about that kidnapping charge
he said I just want to go home
I mean
it's a traffic stop for God's sake
a traffic stop
a simple traffic stop
he's kidnapped for a simple traffic stop
think about that
I mean
yeah this is such an important case
such an important case
and and I continue to think about
people like Terence crudging people who
for simple things having car trouble
and they end up dead when they encounter
the police
Corey Jones
having car trouble when black people
have simple encounters with police
they end up dead we don't hear about
these things with our white brothers and
sisters
we don't see the videos of the police
doing the most with white citizens when
their routine simple matters
all right
and that's where we got to continue to
speak to this police coach in America
it does get emotional because I know
what you're all about to see America and
as much as those five officers killed
Tyree Nichols
it was the police culture in America
that killed Tyree Nichols
so you're going to hear from our civil
rights leader here in Memphis and he's
standing with many other great civil
rights leaders the
SCLC and I know the National Urban
League is also a great presence here in
Memphis but we want to introduce to you
one of our co-counsels who is a great
civil rights leader here our NAACP
president for the Memphis chapter uh
attorney Van Turner
foreign
[Music]
ER
and I'm here
for justice for Tyree
I could really go take my seat after
that
it's really that simple there's not much
else to say
we know the video will be horrific
we know that this happened at Ross and
Reigns
I just found out that this was in an
area that I represented as a county
commissioner
and part of what we did on the
commission was put Sky cameras up in
that Community to help combat crying
little did we know we will be combating
this type of criminal Behavior as well
in that summer
we put Sky cop cameras up to assist the
police
and fighting crime in our community and
yet they come and commit the very same
crimes that we're trying to fight
against
but glory be to God that a skycard
camera was there to catch what happened
and so we want to again stand with this
family I'm here with my cohort
Victorious she's the executive director
We Fight Together
on the on for the cause of the nacp know
that President Derek Johnson has sent
his regards he has sent his soldiers
down from the national office of the
nacp to stand next to this family know
that the nacp National Organization is
standing with this family and we will
fight to the end we will fight with
Attorney Ben Crump we will fight with
this family we will fight with push and
we would fight uh with all those who are
Seeking Justice for Tyree we want to
thank Pastor Thomas for opening this
church up again y'all think Pastor
Thomas give him a hand
we want to thank all those who are here
fighting for justice for Tyree I was at
that Candlelight vigil last night and it
was such a beautiful
world uh look all of Memphis came
together folks who you wouldn't think
could come together came together in
support of this family and that's what
we're going to do we're going to stand
United we're going to peacefully protest
but we're going to protest we're going
to make sure that policy is put forth
and implemented correctly and we're
going to make sure that Tyree Nichols
did not die in vain amen we're going to
make sure that he not die in vain we're
going to keep fighting for him we're
going to keep fighting for this family
y'all pray for this family y'all pray
for our city tonight would be one of the
toughest nights that we've ever
experienced in this city
but we will get through it amen we will
get through it
amen let's stick together let's fight
together
Justice for Tyree
thank you very much
let me know
uh Miss Vicky Tyler one miss Vick and
Terry the executive director of the
NAACP wanted to say a brief word
good morning all and I just wanted to
let Miss Wells know
she is not alone as a mother
I am a mother and I stand here with you
miss Wells proclaiming that there will
be a Tyree Nichols law in Memphis
Tennessee
if there is anything
that I I am saying this today we will
fight together we will support Miss
wells in The Tyree Nichols family I was
listening to listening to her this
morning and as a mother my heart was
breaking right along with yours Miss
Wells I was in tears all morning because
of what is going on in this city because
of what happened to Tyree Nichols Miss
Wells I want to say thank you for
birthing Tyree because he is the
individual that is going to turn this
city around
and fast and Tony Crump said Memphis is
the boot blueprint for what is going to
happen across the country thank you so
much Miss Wells
we are here for you as a mother I am
here and I promise
to do
what I said that I'm going to do and
that is to make Terry Nichols a law in
this city thank you
[Applause]
uh
thank you
they wanted first degree murder they
were not bashful about that
and when you see the video tonight you
will understand that if this was your
child
you would want first degree murder too
but they are respectful and acceptant of
those charges that the district attorney
bought and and they will thank them
in their own way uh now you will hear
from
tyree's dad is his stepfather but
as his mom and his brother and sister
said that's his daddy
let's give a big round of applause for
the man standing strong for his family
Mr Rodney Williams
[Applause]
uh thank you everybody for showing up
I just wanted to say that as Mr Crump
just stated I did push for murder one
from the beginning
that was my main goal
but
as
the charges were told to us
and they explained to us what the
difference between murder one and murder
2 was we're very satisfied with the
charges
more importantly
we want peace
we do not want any type of uproar who do
not want any type of disturbance we want
peaceful protests that's what the family
wants
uh that's what the community wants
uh they're all kind of I got a text
today from one of my supervisors
about an alert
uh telling her don't be in the crowds
tonight
we shouldn't have that
we need to do this peacefully
[Applause]
the family is very satisfied with the
process
uh with the police chief the D.A
they acted very very quickly in this
case
we are very very pleased with that yes
uh other cases drag on but this is a
special case we had a special son
that prompted the quickness of this
results
so
as of The Tyree Nichols family
please please
protest with protest safely thank you
[Applause]
thank you so much Mr Rodney Wales and
now we're going to hear from this
rovonne Wales who
I guess you're talking about dignity and
Grace personified
um
said my son is an assignment from God
let that sink in
your son being sacrificed
his life so that we can have a greater
chance
at Justice fall
Miss
rovonne wells will now dress you
give her a big round of applause
[Applause]
thank you all for coming and showing
support for my family and my son
I really appreciate everything everyone
is doing
my son is looking down smiling because
you know it's funny he always said he
was going to be famous one day
I didn't know this is how he was gonna
this is what he meant but
if
it's a good time
I really don't know what else to say
right now
I've seen so many things in the last few
days
and
really I want to say
I've never seen the video
but what I've heard is very horrific
very horrific
and any of you who have children please
don't let them see it
um
I just want to ask for prayer
from my family for my this whole
community and I want to say to the five
police officers that murdered my son
you also disgraced your own families
when you did this
but you know what I'm gonna pray for you
and your families
because at the end of the day
this shouldn't have happened
that's right this just shouldn't have
happened
and
we want Justice for my son
Justice for my son Justice for Tyree
I just want to thank everybody again for
coming I I don't have I have a lot of
words that I want to say but they
they're just not coming out right
you know you're fine and I still haven't
had time to grieve yet I'm I'm still
dealing with
the death of my son this is
this was not supposed to happen my son
was supposed to be with me today
I'mma always know
that I'll always be with them because I
told everyone he has a tattoo in my name
on his arm
my son loved me to death and I loved him
to death
yes and so this is very difficult for me
I'm sorry if I'm not articulating myself
a little bit better oh you're doing fine
no mother no mother
no mother should go through what I'm
going through right now no mother to
lose their child to the violent way that
I lost my child
thank you
[Applause]
um okay we will try to take your
questions uh and then we will have a
prayer for peace from Bishop Williamson
yes sir and eternal ramanucci
ations
change
it you might as well
my heart just breaks sir
for a mother to know that their child
was calling them in their knee and I
wasn't there for him do you do you know
how I feel right now because I wasn't
there for my son
I told I had an uh
I was telling someone
that I had this really bad pain in my
stomach earlier not knowing what had
happened
but once I found out what happened
that was my son's pain that I was
feeling
and I didn't even know
but for me to find out that my son was
calling my name and I was only your feet
away it was did not even hear him
you have no clue how I feel right now
no clue
thank you
okay we'll try to limit the questions
for Miss uh
whales and we'll try to take all of them
uh you asked why hasn't it changed well
you know
we have been dealing with uh racism and
discrimination in America and you know
racism across the world
for hundreds of years and it's going to
have to be intentional
being able to disseminate deconstruct
racism
and bias
and as I said it it
is the institutionalized police culture
it's not just the police culture it's
the justice system we have bias in every
aspect of society and so
you don't see officers doing this to
White Citizens because our court system
has said
that they Value white life more than any
other life and so we finally have to
speak truth to power on these issues to
say the reason why we keep seeing it
happen to black and brown people is
because it is the culture in this
society that we can marginalize brown
and black people that we can on
the constitutional rights of black and
brown people and that's why we have to
continue to say no it's not equal
justice for some it's Equal justice for
all
you
uh yes
they have a right as any American
citizen
to have a reasonable bail because they
are presumed innocent and to proven
guilty we don't want to change any of
the standards because they are black
police officers whatever has been done
for other officers who were not black
who committed these crimes on video well
it should be equal justice everybody is
Presumed Innocent into proven guilty in
America
understand that this is not the first
time
well you know I'm gonna ask uh my
co-counselor attorney Ramen Nucci and
attorney Turner to speak to those
matters Tony from uh National standpoint
about these specialized units and then
attorney Turner about here in Memphis
so your question was how do we how do we
clean this up yeah
well you have to start with swift
activity and the Swift activity is the
call out to stop and disband this unit
and then from there going in and
restoring trust well how do you restore
trust how about Community Real community
policing as opposed to suppression and
racist policing that's where you have to
start but let me tell you how your
question matches the gentleman's
question in the front row why do we see
this continuing to happen
I'll give you two reasons
it's a two-way street
the community wants it but the other
side doesn't want it the unions don't
want it this is like a carnival you see
the strong man trying to hit the target
and make and ring the bell and it's a
rigged game well we try to ring the bell
but we can't because it's rigged until
we start reform with municipalities in
the union contracts where real reform is
baked in
that's when you'll start seeing real
changes number two
call out the lawmakers in Washington who
failed on the George Floyd on the George
Floyd police Reform Act
call them out
you want change we need Federal change
not only state change
return of ramanucci uh yes Sarah
and
the light on them so I wanted to secure
it before the same thing
this particular incident happened on the
weekend
[Music]
um
Tyree and his dad they work for FedEx
they both work second shift
and they come home for lunch
every day at seven o'clock
I would have dinner cooked they would
eat
hang out and go back to work
well now my husband is coming home every
day but not my son
so
it was a Saturday he was coming from
Shelby Farms for about the time of the
incident because he liked to go and
watch the sunset and take pictures that
was his thing my son loved the sunsets
that was his passion he loved
photography
he loves skateboarding
he was just his own person you know he
he didn't follow what everybody else was
doing I tried to buy him a pair of
Jordans one time and he oh mama I want
those and he bought some bands you know
so
I'm just telling you guys my son was a
beautiful soul
he was a good boy
no one's perfect
but he was damn near
he was close to the home
yes
he was scared for his life
and just what I thought like I said I
didn't see the video but everyone asked
me what I thought happened
and I told them
the TBI people and everybody and I told
them now you proved me wrong
and she said that before she knew about
the video just from seeing the
photograph that they took in the
hospital seeing him in the hospital that
next day with his head swelled uh uh
they said beyond recognition and his
neck swollen pumpkin yeah
so
thank you
I think briefly to try to respond to the
first part of your question as attorney
Robert Nucci said
the police chief should disband the
Scorpion unit immediately
um
I am sad
to even think that what you said is true
that they will use
African-American officers to go berate
African-American citizens because they
thought it would get less attention
uh
we know that other citizens have now
come forward to my office uh saying that
their
constitutional rights were violated by
this scorpion unit and that they
actually try to report them
and nothing happens so
you know we we cannot give anybody a
pass on our
constitutional rights on our dignity on
our Humanity it doesn't matter if it's a
black police officer a white police
officer and that's what hurts so bad
because you want
them to see the humanity in us and you
you keep thinking to yourself these
officers got to understand that you know
that could have been your brother
your little brother Tyree could have
been your little brother would you want
anybody to do what you were doing to
Tyree to your little brother
and that's how
you have to think about it that what if
this was my family member hopefully
every police officer in America would
start thinking when they interact with a
citizen what if this was my brother or
my sister
or my child
that's what we want we want compassion
and respect the same way you de-escalate
with white citizens where I de-escalate
with black citizens too we all want to
get home to our families we want you to
get home to your family and we want to
get on to our mother
uh we'll take a few more
yes and that let's go quick my question
to you is myself as an activist
um and seeing the activists on the stage
um
what are you saying to the activists
that actually need boots on the ground
because I know that you all are you know
legal team and you always are here
whenever we need you as far as the legal
realm but the activist is really the
ones that's out there bringing attention
to the family situation
[Music]
um
and myself personally in this field have
been pushed off by you know legal team
knowing that I'm staying for the
families and even talking to other
Advocates to actually stand for these
families and actually are being the
voice out there what do you tell them
whenever they're the ones out there
fighting for the family and to be pushed
off and not to be you know heard
one of the first things I always try to
do and as silk and Kareem and a lot of
people who are activists end up working
for my Law Firm because when you have a
commitment to Justice that's what we
want to be about and I always want to
thank the activists every press
conference the first thing I do is come
and think the activist because without
you all we wouldn't be at this point
nobody was talking about Justice for
Tyree like Kareem Ali and you all I mean
yeah I kept saying there's something
going on with this attorney crop and I
want to applaud you all privately and
publicly because without you all we're
going to get Justice for Tyree we
wouldn't got Justice for George Floyd we
wouldn't have got Justice for Ahmad
Ivory we want to get Justice for Brianna
Taylor we're about the activists serving
as our co-counsels there's no way we can
get justice so we thank all the
activists community
[Applause]
murder charges does your office believe
there is sufficient evidence to possibly
pursue upgraded charges
well I'll say this and then I'll let uh
Tony speak I I think that
the D.A
had the benefit of being able to slow
down the tape and dissect the video and
look at Blow by blow kick by Kick uh
strike by strike with the police stick
you know every aspect of it so I want to
believe that they try to show respect to
Mr Mrs Wells and charge them with the
most they felt they could get a
conviction on and make no mistake about
it the video
when you all said you all try to think
to yourself what are the correct charges
because we all
don't we all got eyesight we don't need
anybody to interpret it for us you look
at that video for yourself and you say
we're the actions intentional I mean
when you you kicking somebody and you
it's not a reaction kit you actually
like stutter for a minute and make sure
that you get to kick in that seems
intention is anything you can imagine
to turn around man don't you yes I think
who just want to say let him respond to
this again yeah I just want to confirm
lest anybody ever thought that there was
an exaggeration or an overstatement as
to what you will see number one look at
the charges read the charges and you
will see that there has been none
secondly our independent medical autopsy
our medical examiner and this and I'm
allowed to give the quote she said that
these injuries are consistent with the
severe beating
that is the quote so when you take that
quote and you understand what we've seen
and what the charges are
those are maximum charges murder
requires a little bit more something and
I agree with Ben that the state's
attorney looked at these charges and did
whatever they could whether or not there
was any other charges out there well
maybe the evidence will bear that out
but don't forget this is what the
charges bear out when you look at the
medical examiner and the charges there's
consistency
thank you Tony and remember on the video
there's some audio so you will hear
audio and that is very compelling
because it kind of tells what your
intent is when you say things uh yes sir
well we we look forward to getting the
radio uh transactions and any calls that
were made because we don't know anything
other than we got to see the video so uh
they said he was driving recklessly
you know
we have to see it we certainly can't
take their word for it uh and if not
then it goes to what attorney ramanucci
said a lot of these stops are pretext
stops
you know uh yes ma'am
during the day my job I wear a black
hole
I'm judge chin
I'm in traffic court I've been there for
26 years people have asked why I stayed
in and it's to ensure for a system that
suggesting fear that starts here yes
ma'am in these years when I get new
officers I ask them to remember four
things
treat people the way that you want to
dream
right be treated
you want them to treat members of their
families
they're that way
make it home to your family
and don't take any unnecessary risk to
remember that people that you interact
with going to make it home to their
families too right I'm sorry that
whatever happened that evening that
the message wasn't received
and I'm giving you my sincere companies
and I'm going to continue
as a judge not to hide behind the black
robe like I can't stand right now
[Applause]
a system that's just
for everyone
because I've been stopped for suspecting
firmly I would stop Force affected
in an area
a few weeks ago I had a gentleman who
was stopped and was upset because the
police didn't show him nothing
tell him why they were stopping me
and he had his daughters when he was
going to be a man and show his daughters
who have rights
and I explained to a serve
your objective is to get who
you fighting for it amen
[Applause]
myself
because I'm speaking for Jane Chandler
of the mother
thank you thank you I'm so sorry thank
you James
okay last question
yes ma'am
communication
the patterns
kilo images
the prior to his death
three other people for daily shot
remember
it
is
families of those victims were
the Bell
yes ma'am as a
National civil rights attorney we go to
many
municipalities and communities and you
often hear about other tragedies uh that
happened before
the high profile case that's going on
and what we try to do is
try to lift all of the injustices up and
we try to speak to all of those and
hopefully at Future rallies for justice
for Tyree we invite those families to
stand with Miss Wells and Mr Wells
because
none of these tragedies are any more
important than any of the others all of
our children matter and we have to
continue to say that each and every one
of our children
have a right to live on this Earth to
breathe in another breath and so we have
to continue to do that I I would hope
that the city leadership if the
Department of Justice
deems it appropriate to have a pattern
in practice investigation of the Memphis
Police Department that they will welcome
it that they won't try to fight or
object to
hopefully that the city council members
will say that we want to have an
internal audit of ourselves let's just
don't
look outward and try to get resentful
and crumping all us lawyers start saying
that there's a problem
with police culture because you know the
best way
to solve the problems with police
culture
is for the police to work with the
community
and be transparent
accept accountability
and build trust
that is how
you can deal with this culture and they
may attack us and try to say oh oh they
continue to uh attack police as we often
said
we are not
anti-police we're anti-bad police who
killed Tyree who killed George Floyd who
lying killed Brianna Taylor who lying
killed uh Alton Sterling are all these
people who
Ronald green I met uh
Jake
Jalen ramble absolutely we we're against
those officers
who Skirt the Rules
to justify
these unjustifiable killers
of our children just Chandler that's who
we're against and if you want to help us
if you want to take this argument away
from us
there help us fix the police culture
where we can go
another
month two months three months four
months five months without the media
rushing to the next city to report on
the latest hashtag that becomes part of
American
society and y'all know the names we
don't even have to explain them to you
that's how bad it is when we say Michael
Brown
when we say Tamir rice
when we say Alton Sterling when we say
Eric God now when we say Stefan Clark
when we say laquan McDonald when we say
philando Castile when we say Dante
Wright when we say Amir lock
I mean
Tatiana Jefferson
is that not a a systematic problem with
the culture when you have these many
unarmed black people dying
we're not talking about people who got
guns coming at the police
because we look at the data attorney
ramanucci is uh you know van Turner I
mean these are great lawyers
we don't just go willy-nilly we look at
statistics we look at when the police
have to use uh daily force with white
citizens
it's normally where a citizen has a
deadly weapon that's not true when we
look at Daily encounters with black
people and police
I mean how many times
do we have to hear another black man was
shot in the back while he was running
away from the police and the police say
I felt and fear of my life
that doesn't happen often with white
citizens
that's why we're saying it's a cultural
matter within the police department and
unless we are willing to be honest
and say there's an issue these black
people aren't crazy
they were using excessive force against
us but they don't want to say that they
rather try to attack us and say oh y'all
are race faders and so forth just
because we have the audacity to come and
take a stand for our children
I mean it's like Malcolm X said that
they call you racist for confronting
their racism
and so we have an opportunity here in
America to really speak to this
institutionalized police culture that
show that it's not just about
white officers
are black officers Or Hispanic officers
it's about police officers
having this
biased belief
that you can get away with doing certain
things
to Black citizens and brown citizens in
America that you cannot get away with
with white citizens
we have to have this conversation
America
Terry Nichols
Miss Wells is right
God used him
to tell us to have this conversation
thank you we uh will ask for a prayer
and peace
as we prepare for the six o'clock
Central Time release of the video while
the world
will see why
we have to get Justice for Tyree and we
have to use this to say no more
thank you
thank you uh we're going to have prayer
from Bishop Williamson uh the spiritual
leader of this Cathedral
to
get peace
let's give God thanks
for Attorney Benjamin crime
[Applause]
we've done
let us now pray with compassion
and love
for this family
of this young man
Tyree
let us
believe God that we're not just going to
be with them today
but in the weeks ahead the counseling
that they need
for this traumatic event
that's why I represent all churches in
all faith and all religious communities
many of the Humanity Against Humanity or
these five policemen we also are
remembering the Holocaust
and our Jewish who lost 6 million
so this
Humanity Against Humanity
the series of lynchings we've had for
the last 400 years
and so we praying for this family today
and all families that have suffered
Injustice at the hands of the police
because of the racist culture and we
recognize it's just a few
but even one is too much amen
would you buy your ears sir now God we
ask you to comfort
this family his mother and his father
we ask you to strengthen them yes this
mother has recognized he was on a
mission
to transform This Racist culture so that
Justice
might prevail
his life
was given
we in the Christian culture know God had
to give his son
to die to bring Salvation to the world
and so this mother knows that her son
was on a mission
and his life has been given to bring
correction
to make sure that
Justice happens
that our children are safe in the
streets and in the schools and driving
we thank you God
we thank you Lord
for Tyree Justice for Tyree comfort for
his family comfort for his mother and
father covered for his family comfort
for his brothers and sisters comfort
dog strengthen Give Peace Give Peace but
let change come
let change come to this city nation and
world let's change come let there be
peace on Earth
and let it begin in Russia and Ukraine
but in the city and streets of Memphis
Tennessee amen
appoint an investigative committee to
move forward with police reform and
thank you God
that the police chief was sensitive and
moved forward we thank you for chief
David moving and now we have a blueprint
for Action going forward in our city
state nation and world
and all of the people of God said in one
voice from this man amen
amen and amen
come on give God your praise for this
family
and his father and more alternatively
thank you Bishop
okay the funeral will be 10 30 on
Wednesday and uh Bishop uh
Mississippi Boulevard Church
Dr J Lawrence Turner is the uh
pastor of that church Reverend Al
Sharpton would deliver the eulogy and
they're asking for all members of the
clergy both black and white to come out
and show Unity for this family and this
community thank you
tonight we're saying to all citizens
Let There Be Peace On Earth and peace in
the streets
of Memphis and Shelby County
thank you so very much